how does Europe's strongest economy
stays strong in the face of billions of
Chinese investment and of course the US
dominant position in digital technology
Germany's economy minister Peter
admirers says his government has found
an answer here's a look now at the key
points of the country's industry
strategy 2030 sure up Europe's economic
motor and armor German companies like
Siemens and Tyson crop against hostile
takeovers that's the goal of the German
government's new investment strategy
after recent years saw China buy up one
company after the other Germany's
economic affairs minister says Berlin
can't afford to sell its high-tech
patents to foreign powers I think that
when certain countries and specific
companies use very aggressive tactics to
expand their market share then we have
the right and responsibility to respond
altameyer also said German companies
needed to lead the pack when it comes to
innovation in new technologies like
artificial intelligence or battery
development for electric cars Berlin is
planning to help kick-start that
development with billions in new
investment which could also help protect
German jobs all right let's get some
reaction from Frankfurt Power Christian
but it's a standing by power it sounds
like millions of euros are about to come
to German industries away is that good
use well by the looks of it that money
will be will be reserved for hostile
takeovers and if a Chinese investment in
the past month a fee as we just heard a
minute ago is any indicator it may
actually work as a deterrent and never
see the light of day but it's good we're
talking about champions and that
possibly there's some some money free
because a saving current champions from
from drowning struggling champions may
not be the way for the future but maybe
investing in infrastructure and actually
making sure that small midsize companies
can work on problems like artificial
intelligence self-driving car
and innovate because they have the
infrastructure the digital
infrastructure that might be the right
way to go all right Paul Campbell it's
in Frankfurt thank you
you